gracias la codicia si no había tenido un
efecto devastador en la salud mental de
las personas en las américas lo que
afecta sobre todo la salud del bienestar
y por supuesto la estabilidad económica
de toda la región de las américas el
estrés el miedo y el trauma relacionado
con la pandemia creada de una crisis de
salud mental en toda la región a lo
largo de la pandemia el estrés y el
miedo han invadido nuestra vida
cotidiana lo que ha provocado un aumento
de problemas de salud mental
relacionados con ansiedad y depresión la
amenaza en general del cobat ha obligado
a las personas como todos lo sabemos hay
las a islas nos de nuestros amigos de
nuestros familiares y por supuesto un
porcentaje muy alto de la población ha
perdido su trabajo y lucha por mantener
a sus familias
bueno esto nos dice que el estrés y el
miedo vienen a lo largo del tiempo y no
solo en la pandemia pero a pesar de esto
según la misma o ps el gasto público
promedio en salud mental en américa es
del 2 por ciento esto es 0,8 por ciento
menos que la media mundial
las consecuencias de esto
esto tiene unos efectos muy importantes
en la medida en que no hay recursos
suficientes pues las personas no tienen
el acceso suficiente para recibir
tratamiento si tienen problemas
asociados con trastornos en salud mental
en tiempos de pandemia igualmente los
servicios de salud se han
acortado y la gente no ha tenido la
posibilidad de acceder a los servicios
es muy importante ver la posibilidad de
que los gobiernos incrementen mucho más
el gasto público en los servicios de
salud mental y hablando precisamente del
papel de los gobiernos la organización
panamericana de la salud ha dicho que
chile costa rica y trinidad y tobago son
modelos a seguir en lo que respecta a la
atención psicosocial vamos en esos
planes y porque son captan
característicos
bueno supongo que están haciendo un
trabajo muy importante para que las
poblaciones vulnerables tengan un mayor
acceso a servicios de salud en este
sentido han fortalecido entonces la
salud mental comunitaria y han hecho que
la salud mental no solamente sea una
responsabilidad de salud sino que
también sectores como educación
protección sectores como el trabajo
tengan en cuenta la salud mental de toda
la población el tema de salud mental no
es responsabilidad solamente de salud
sino debe ser un tema transversal y e
intersectorial para realmente disminuir
las brechas de acceso a la salud de toda
la población